Hey good morning our neighbors just came
and gave us juice and oh my god damn
whoa I can just smell the fat and sugar
from OD damn they look good
charcoal lemonade whoa oh that's weird
I guess it's good for you I don't I
don't know i would normally feel kind of
weird because they obviously seen my
vlogs but they were so cold i don't know
they weren't jumping with a camera
trying to take pictures in our houses to
say that feels so good with a weekend i
finally have some time off me and marts
are gonna hang out today I'm really
excited but first I'm gonna go on a
quick run
I love running in another country it's
so interesting to like just look around
and oh my god are you trying to be cacey
nice day
come on come on yeah but we're not doing
that huh
burn our love case yes he's cool but
come on
oh my mouth is just watering up like her
MOT yeah you gotta see these no I can't
because they look like a million
calories per by no I'm not gonna you
gotta fix this I can't go out like this
what do you want me to do just beef just
fix it okay I don't want to walk around
with the cat's butthole try and cover
the penises Oh something cute make it
into flowers this is what you do you
touch things and they become cute well
flower penis great that's so much better
what did you do hug it what is this do
you think that's funny
look it god damn it okay so we're going
to Little Tokyo now or Bates Motel might
says obsessed with Bateman style so you
kids stay safe now
[Music]
so excited for a good run I wrapped it
like 4 a.m. last night it's I'm really
tired
[Music]
I felt like we were drowning there for a
second
where we getting stopped like every five
seconds and I was desired take me out
over here
I can't everyone is really sweet but it
gets too much when like can I take a
picture can I take a picture can I take
a picture I think we need to get out of
here
[Music]
I think Marta is having a great time but
I'm dying I'm so tired
don't tell her though I really want to
just sleep
I don't know this is not it
what did the hell is this you know you
had to right yeah I said that I was like
that was too right
like no it's a pig so far another one
another hey Felix I wanted you to be the
one of the first people but I already
used to watch for like yes thanks
Suzanne from Google I mean I love the
pixel but I'm really disappointed that I
was expecting another package sorry so
ungrateful I got a pixel boom but like
it's not what I wanted I bet now that
we're coming back
we're gonna miss the new package that
always happened something that did
arrive though was this if you're not
familiar with raspberry pie it's a very
tiny computer and I'm gonna build it
into a camera I don't know I've never
done it before but I thought it might be
cool so I'll probably [ __ ] up but here
we go
all right it's running I'm going to now
try and do my first picture with a
camera with a camera I'm excited enable
camera done now okay
I got a reboot this is cool
I'm excited here we go
hey whoa Shay I didn't expect that okay
talk do you see this okay cameras
warming so it's automatically going to
keep taking pictures I'm really excited
to test out some time lapse for Roberta
bow now I really got to do something
else I spend too much time on this but
it's pretty cool
[Music]
all right guys minds is really hungry so
we're gonna go outside and eat we're
going on this really creepy road
la so trashy yeah that's right la I
called you out come on it looks it looks
like we could get stabbed here you
better stay close Marzia I'll protect
you from all the stabbing people and
cars okay let's run let's run they're
dangerous you don't want to die Marzia
that's why I'm here all right anyway so
anyway this vlog has not been the most
exciting maybe but it's been a nice
chill day and you know what I think I
really need right now a vegan burger I'm
always scared crossing the street in LA
I guess we're supposed to go there's no
light what are we doing
we're just supposed to go
this breakfast [ __ ]
alright we got an extra sandwich because
they recognize this thank you very much
it is really cool how you get you know a
lot of you guys are very nice and polite
and give us free [ __ ] appreciate it I
was a little sad though today that we
couldn't I couldn't really enjoy going
to Little Tokyo because I felt like we
were watching me every second like I
kept getting stopped constantly I don't
know that kind of kind of ruins it for
me a little bit so it is that it is a
you know potato potato you know what I'm
Atta all right I set it up over the
night it's probably gonna look [ __ ]
because I haven't got a battery for it
yet so I have to put it there I just
want to test it out but it kind of feels
like fishing a little bit like you have
to place it down and see what you get
I'll see you tomorrow buddy all right
well I had a lovely day when Mark said
really good time I think it would be a
really entertaining blog what do you
think the title and thumbnail will be
earthquake oh that's quick yeah there
was enough that's going to be an
earthquake apparently there is going to
be enough there's going to be an
earthquake that's why we're stood
outside because we need a title because
we need to tie on the thumb now and
we've been praying to mother nature
they sexually the name that they plan on
thumb now yeah it's time but darling
thumbnail don't buy bread house of
YouTube how do you tube get any content
you want a lie about the thumbnail and
title alright that's the most important
bit and that's the most important that's
how the YouTube how do you tube 2016 you
can enjoy the video that much as you
like would have be betting clicking on
it it'll mean [ __ ] right
like
Oh freakin you feel that I didn't feel
it what is it I think it's coming oh my
god
the first California
[Music]
ah
how is the camera so stable Oh scary Oh
quite thumbnail how's that is that good
this way send the money shot this one
honey shy that's how you do YouTube
thanks for C 2x boozy alright another
day another bird about I hope I didn't
give you guys mixed messages about
meeting in person if you ever see me I
want you to come and say hi I really do
I'm just trying to like I said I want
Berta bow to be honest vlogs and I'm
just trying to explain my perspective on
things and I hope you understand but
regardless thank you guys so much for
watching another episode and I'll see
you tomorrow with another one and as
always
[Music]